siamo sotto casa tv e penso stia
dormendo perché abbastanza presto
abbiamo preferito più non è da casa sua
e quindi ora ci intrufoliamo nella sua
abitazione
speriamo di non farlo cagare sotto sa
che qui sapevo che sei sentito la
subiamo
a si svegliò lascio allentamento
di elmo elmo niente guglielmo abbiamo
preso le chiavi da nonna non ti abbiamo
fatto una sorpresa può una successo
sotto devi scendere fino adesso ha paura
ripido nel letto ma già ma che è brutto
ma non fino a questo punto dai ti
aspettiamo un errore arriva da sempre
meta buongiorno ragazzi a questo punto
credo che questo sia una nuova puntata
il blog massa che cos'è lieti con dei
trucchi
ma di cosa mai vista al ahmar che ti ha
fatto un regalino ragazze cinghia che i
veneti sono sono conti vista
quindi ci stai facendo mi pulisco gli
occhiali ecco questo che è il rossetto
no gianmarco meno gianmarco no quello è
un credo sia un fondotinta
questo è un mascara per dillo che non
sono preparati in materia rosa e mascara
no questo rossetto è un settore
neroscuro viola e come ti chiudi scusa
che non lo so vedendo il volo abbiamo
una palette per fare scouting qualcosa
di natalizio è infatti che cosa
natalizio anch'io tra fondotinta ma non
dovevo farlo
già lo fa ci aspetta qualche anno e
domani di più paga ma se facciamo innati
por n tv rudolf perché anche speranze di
make up
io però ho studiato un sacco di video
tra clio e alice arena ma pure con le
corna
vabbè per quelle ci pensa luigi che fai
certo per truccarsi uno dovrebbe essere
liscio a me nomea di s ma in arena ci si
lava che faccio prendo queste qui mi
diplomo ok ragazzi benvenuti al mio
tutorial non ho mai fatto una cosa
simile ma sono contenta per far star
sfilata sulla resa nota anche come
caribou in nord america o in certi delle
regioni artiche subartiche vuoi che ti
cerco qualche di jolo a questo punto
vorrei sapere che verso fa la renna se
non etico un incrocio tra una pecora e
luca
bellissimo assolutamente delizioso sono
un po che sto lavorando che abbiano
sposato un secondo ragazze questi due
fondi che sono al n w45 lnc 13 al quale
lo raggiungo nelle zone di transizione
anche scusate ragazze questo nc20 in
questo modo io creavo già delle ombre
già dal fondo intanto messo vedi dei
fondotinta diversi a seconda delle zone
sulle guance hanno messo molto più scuro
sulle parti invece più illuminate l'ho
messo più chiaro e quindi già mi faccia
sembrare denutrito infatti più marrone
arrivando a rientare veramente aladin
mettiamo un po di correttore quello
cerca tivo questo di ore che tu sembra
sia anche col muso da renna a quattro
zampe
le pare adesso col colore più scuro
io vado a queste c'è colore che tiene in
abbondanza sotto così che ti levi il
doppio evento
se poi c'è quello nero oppure per te ti
odio ti ho esagerato ma non spetta
cercando almeno un po questa situazione
effettivamente la quale circa una renna
sembra ustionato a questo è il grido di
valore
io faccio secondo fame ok in questo
momento sono aladin aler in chi è andato
in vacanza a sciare è venuta un'idea
ragazzi cerco di mettere un pochino di
questo colore anche qua perché sennò
sembrerò una povera pazza un'arena
arzilla quasi quasi sembra né
rinoplastica che ve ne pare
mi sono dimenticato una cosa
importantissima questa polvere e
cipriano sto facendo baking adoro tutto
questo biking mafia
lasciamo agire questa farina vedi da lo
tolgo creditore si fa il corpo il coach
è troppo distante aspettano collo non so
sbatti credo che jack e rose avessero
meno stress quando stavano scappando da
morte certa usciamo via dall arena
tipica e andiamo così guardati da cedere
sempre qualcosa che si ha a che fare coi
serbi di mi auguro ok questo è un po
bambino funziona si parla o sei
fortunato appartiene alla famiglia dei
cervi dice piatto perfetto da quando mi
è un po più acuto positivo cazzarola
funziona ed ecologia in su ma non è
bellissimo
[Musica]
adesso sto sfumando con un big mac 170
importantissimi questo se no non ti
viene questo effetto non ha per il
momento ci siamo una istanza bello beh
tu stai creando il tuo esemplare servite
a questo punto la mia idea sapete qual è
di estendere leggermente questa roba
anche nell'occhio
purtroppo c'è una palpebra calante
camera bassa
effettivamente sembra sembra un arena
avanti con l'età è di 42 a un cervi dai
15 e 25 anni
quest'anno vent'anni in vent'anni di
quest'amore dovrà essere morta devo
creare un effetto occhi boom aspettano
secondo gli animali gela il problema
delle borse sotto gli occhi ma che ma
per matti pare che adesso ci interessa
sapere se gli animali hanno le borse
sopra partita i pruriti che c'hanno gli
animali ma non la volevano questo è il
tuo ragionamento di oggi prego mi piace
un sacco
pensa se alla renda di fondo ma doveva
usiamo adesso il mach 217 s per andare a
coprire un pochino l'anno si problema
più dragan the portare via la cavano
meglio mettere un marrone scuro iniziamo
a per renderlo anche un po più freddo
lui a questa altezza con la renault io
mi sto divertendo un sacco spero che
anche da casa gli state divertendo
scusate se non vi faccio vedere i
passaggi precisi stata d oro scuro
vicino all'occhio l'occhio l'oscuro pc
con l'occhio st detti a spam spa ma
metto un pochino di bianco qui ma si
vedrà
i vapori dei trucchi e polverini
adesso vado a fare una linea di eyeliner
bella prepotente other black mai odio
raga io non so come funziona ti serve
concentrazione che minchia egizio un
egizio però ho fatto male è difficile
per i giudici le zampe di gallina razzi
ma come fate voi apparvero fatemi
salvare hanno bastonato sbarella ragazzi
e ragazze vi truccate ci ho messo sette
anni non so se vedete tutti i tentativi
che ho fatto sulla mano mi ha fatto poi
man mano pure citofonato so dovuto
scendere perché mi hanno dato due
contravvenzioni sono andato lì lei
puliamo sheila purtroppo sì ho firmato
non so nemmeno per cosa sola andiamo
avanti a questo punto mi sono pure
dimenticando del suo mancino un destro
io veramente vorrei fare un complimento
a tutte quante le ragazze ei ragazzi che
si sanno truccare ok montiamo le ciglia
finte loro mano mandato queste e quindi
queste metterò lo resterà con la gamma
hanno dato rabbia siamo sulla scia
quanto è tosta non passò uffici bisogna
soffiare sulle ciglia vero oddio oddio
non sai come sto facendo
sto andando a sensazione di bagnato il
santo barney adulti lo sto attaccando
commessa di milano rimane ti prego di
manici rimani scola con la colla con la
valle p group i due non so se le ho
messe benissimo in questo momento ci
stanno
fatto naso si stanno anche carino che
sono non so se funzionano io lo faccio
cioè il fondo a 76 detto a guardare così
la materia sotto l'obiettivo della tuta
in bocca celani posso dire che non è
farsi pubblico invece si confessa su per
carini
figurati lui che è uno zoologo e ataf ha
chiuso solo sopra voi incerpi del
abbastanza partita raccapricciante come
di sta mettendo questore adesso se ci
vide timbrati tuttovela dei dentisti ma
ovviamente quelli tubo che serve per
succhiare la saliva la accadeva una paga
per fare con jacob invece ecco perché le
rendevano così
[Applauso]
[Risate]
il rossetto è rimasta attaccata un pezzo
di licata
non so che di ci sta ragazzi dai faccio
il corno nere che partono dalle ciglia
le vorrei farle dalle colonne sonore ac
dai cordoni che ovviamente non si
dovrebbero mai fare neve però cosa fate
le corna di un'arena mi fate vedere
delle cose abbiamo le sopracciglia di s
ok marrone adesso di grandi grandi
meravigliosi meravigliosi grazie ma
matita marrone e vediamo che cosa fanno
ok questa è la base tra le diverse
sembra sempre un po un cimitero ma sono
più allegro questa pianta sia alcun e
poi anche continuare crd si dà è mai
stata così contento né per le corna da
sono corna
mi sono sfinito sono esausto s'è fatta
notte mettere il giusto un pochino di
matita sotto matita bianca dentro la
circum era stato solo provato che si
ristrutturano distrutto voi dovete
vedere la barca la testa tra le mani ma
è venuta un ultima idea
un cacciatore di rende le lenti rosa
facciamolo subito bisogna trovare il
nome
rosa adesso gara sembri la bbc delle
donne oddio ma ora devo fare una cosa
che fa più di tutte quante le beauty
guru che è questa i momenti in cui si
sparano le cose alla fine perché fanno
sta cosa fanno così falsi loro solamente
questo per far vedere bene il trucco e
poi c'è questo gli occhi lato sono le
moschee mi girano attorno come il verso
bari aspetta che cosa pochino padre
ancora ma facciamo il terzo affacciato
al balcone come un richiamo si
bellissimo ci sono certo ma perché devo
essere umiliato e mortificato miei vice
ideye salta basta con jeans facci vedere
che non trovo lo struccante meno così
per sempre
sì sì minuscolo maggio nome come si fa
un goccio di soia in quell intingolo
fighissimo tenere dolce mamma e acilia e
lenti ma cos'è che è successo a questo
il fatto che regola contro questo bacio
proprio per far prezzo
parliamo non ti delude mai
acqua calda poi mi sparo un sacco di
questa la vediamo
e chiuderla dai ragazzi ciao cascate gli
occhi aperti e domani